i was talking to uh maurice clarett the
other day
and man i really really admire that guy
he has so much solution in his in his
brain and in his heart and
and uh and
and he was saying you know one of the
reasons people are all so antsy right
now he thinks because
nobody has anything to do there's no
sports to watch there's no outlet
the only teams that have been playing
this whole time
have been political so everybody's
getting on one or the other
um so it's just it's interesting and i
thought about that people have become
more
fans of politics
you know we've become more fan it's
become
without other sports and other things
politics has become the thing to be a
fan of
you know i like this quarterback i like
this quarterback oh the backup
quarterbacks
you know is racist the black the the
black up quarterback's racist you know
it's just
there's all it just there's people are
becoming fans of politics
and becoming activists that's one thing
i'm just do we've all i fee
i feel like we've all become such
addicts to all of this junk
that is then making us be
angry about stuff that i don't know if
we're really angry about
i know that we are concerned about
things
i know that we have views about things
but i don't know if we're really
angry about things
so i really question the the side effect
of
just all the snippets and all the
information and the constant barrage
of information
and the effect that has on us
you know it's just because you start to
wonder well everybody
like so many people are activists now
like what's going on
like i get being activated
but at some point it's just
we're i feel like
we're being taken advantage of you know
at some point we feel a little bit used
by all of the just the media and all the
hype
and a lot of it's like panic porn
you know my brother's friend coined that
phrase and i don't know his last name
it's i think he's a
latino fellow but panic porn where you
just
everybody's getting some we're getting
some f some
some dopamine hit in our brain by
getting off on all of this uh
this political and social jack-jack
um and i made it up to black belt dang
dude i'm not sure i don't think so
i don't think so i don't think so i
don't honestly
you know it's uh i mean what would riley
mouse say he don't know that's what he
would say bro
so you got to think about that sometimes
or don't think about it
and those are the options good evening
good afternoon and other times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw i mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better what if you watch a video
right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one